it's an enormous privilege to have an
adolescence and to an extent rarely
spoken about not everyone gets the
chance to have one adolescence isn't
just a particular time of one second
decade and it won't unfold automatically
simply when one reaches 14 or 17 and
three quarters
adolescence properly understood is a
state in which we're able to explore
with courage and Newfound Independence
who we might be outside of the
projections and mental dictates placed
upon us with enormous Ingenuity and
great force by our parents
parents are the greatest propagandists
that any of us will ever meet with and
part of their genius is that we rarely
know what they are up to below the
surface they are engaged in a ruthless
and ongoing attempt to sell us a version
of reality to tell us what we are really
like what we actually need what life is
truly about and who they have been and
what their motives are
it goes without saying that some of
their ideas will be eminently correct
but the function of adolescence is to
take a good long look at and deal with
the ones that aren't
adolescence is an initially inarticulate
and then gradually more Discerning
protest against everything that has come
to feel false ill-fitting and
superfluously applied to our identities
since we were born we may realize as we
progress through adolescence that we
really aren't interested in particular
sides of the workplace that our parents
have held in high esteem that we don't
care about a given approach to morality
or vision of politeness and goodness and
that we would prefer to join the circus
or Goldman Sachs
good parents are secure enough not to
mind they can accept that their child
may have turned into that always rather
remarkable thing a separate person they
can even take it if their children are
Furious for a while try to kill them in
their imaginations and see all their
incompetence and stupidity without a
filter of sentimentality or fear what
clever people they are to be able to
perceive things so distinctly what a
tribute to one's parenting to allow such
loathing to play out
the difficulty lies with the parents who
broke no such opposition who are too
vengeful depressed or anxious to
tolerate dissent and force us to disown
bits of ourselves in order to retain
their love
the good news is that it's never too
late for an adolescence we can start to
have one as soon as we realize our right
to Define ourselves away from parental
laws we can even do it in secret
without spots to give things away no one
will have to know the critical task that
is at play beneath our sober middle-aged
facades a belated search for our true
selves